insomma martelli beckley bellissimo
corte di de bravo e questo non è il
nuovo gillet per fare la barba gillet il
meglio di un uomo del passato tutto
microfono ciao marco ma come cazzo ti
chiami io mi ricordo ciao zio pia in
questa palla nell'occhio
come l'hai preso io non ci credo non ci
credo
aspettami di lasciare non lo so avevamo
a caso il tubo
[Musica]
eccolo il lavandina non è l'avandia ci
ho messo un'ora e mezza per non era
questo ma [ __ ] prova a farne una
un po miglia minchia come l'ho calciato
ronaldinho ha fatto gol
poco o con il pogo fatto gol
in avanti c'è qualcos'altro che lo
faccia
salve io prendo un po il sole qui se non
ti dispiace grazie tu vai pure negli
inferi madonna che schifo
madonna che più schivo ancora mica frate
dai è diventata cos'è parkinson ha
rivali propri social parkinson o mio dio
cos'era
se non scappi prima del tempo morirai
tanti auguri sono perfetto quanto tempo
è una domanda che non necessita più di
disposta ragazzi vi prego ragazzi
canzoni di major lazer qua sotto mentre
avanti livello ed è così che si passa la
domenica mattina error ho capito la
[ __ ] ragazzi mi sono caga tissimo
perché avevo il volume al massimo delle
cuffie io mio tipo stordito l'avrebbe ma
una tisana non ve la fate voi rock swing
folk were all coop tanto quello il corpo
è contento che io faccio i suoi livelli
però qualcuno si sul traguardo è la
coratella mi il cic porca eva per la
mancanza incantarci che ripensa ai remix
[Musica]
si sente
io
bellissimo
a me ci sta un po di gabry ponte sullo
sfondo che dite
[Musica]
e vabbè ma non posso ben davanti ciao
rota smic addio cosa vuoi che faccia
averne capito ti odio non riesco a
parlare questa cosa che brutta
sensazione non fatevi domande non
chiedetemi perché ho una maschera di
jigsaw in casa ai zitto zitto 99 per
cento in posti come facciamo questo
[Musica]
credo che sia la morte per
un'impossibile più bella che abbia mai
fatto c'è veramente geniale il casse
finco così nome non ci credo non ci
credo miskolc a che mi aiutò polizia
sono stato sequestrato dove va beh
guarda che dopo un po l'atmosfera
finisce non sono la cosa che ti dico io
perché sono studiato mentre saltava mi è
entrato seggiolino nella schiena come
possibile solo seduta sul seggiolino
ciao fa vi sono io nella live hai fatto
il primo oggi il secondo spero ti
piaccia
ok
grazie per avermi fatto saltare i
timpani così a cazzo di cane zio ce la
puoi fare [ __ ] avere grazie niente
skrillex niente montagne e fotte sega
bellissimo del meraviglioso di più bella
che io abbia mai visto in tutta la mia
vita si è anche fatto di ketamina
probabilmente già ora che da mons
e tutto così che non ingombra bene io sì
che so fare lo youtube bello ti piace
questo livello non so che di
intelligente lo stesso a tutti gli altri
partiamo con l'impossible visto che
ancora non ho visto visto che ancora non
ho visto imparato a parlare come parla
fa vj soprattutto a morire come muore
per l'alto ragazzi la tizia con l'ananas
in testa sembra che balli un qualcosa di
tropicale e io mi sto godendo la scena
così sdraiato non ce l'ho fatto dio la
scopa ieri potter o filippi o bellissimo
non vedo un cazzo che cosa mi limiterò e
bacchetta allora secondo te un consiglio
bene che cazzo di consiglio e dimmi
qualcosa ma [ __ ] o una triste vita
questo mi sa che abbastanza grosso non
so sicuri perciò mi inchino alla sua
supremazia
due attacchi in via saba più tectonic
kenny non smettiamo tectonic va bene
basta sono giochi per bambini di due
anni vedi non fare figure di merda
salta c'è io sono la persona che riesce
a crepare anche nei parco giochi
spiegazione fornita miyake salto cos'è
successo
lo zio diviene la dal mio culo però
[Musica]
preferireste essere immortale ma povero
ricco ma mortale grazie al cazzo che
immortalano povero porca eva e ricchi si
compra una bella tomba e io ci piscio
sopra ad e voce michele il casinò è ma
veramente
[Musica]
che bello questo fazzoletto che bello
potrà ammirarlo per ora questo
fazzoletto guarda la parola happy wings
april li vedi tutti questi triangoli
silvio però devi farti meno pippe
mentali che è che è lo sapevo di trovare
qua sotto sbaglio ok
non so perché ho fatto così però questa
è una pagina
sto facendo uno sword trovo senza
muovere la mano fantastico ho finito i
soldi da trussardi
ma la va bene non è possibile come etica
questo è lo stesso messaggio di prima e
la vita è bella
finché non ti prendi un lampadario al
neon in faccia potresti potrebbe fare
potrebbe vincere potrebbe vincere liga i
gremi sapere l'italiano è famosa la mia
fortuna è caduto burana lenti c'e
fantastico
sì
make your choice io lo faccio meglio
fermin attimo
allora se non ti muovi li entro 5
secondi ti ammazzo la famiglia la
famiglia anzi tra torturo la famiglia
sulla bell'ultimo cose cosa va la
[ __ ] va bene va bene ciao ciao mamma
sono famoso cosa che faccio il successo
[Musica]
fermi cosa come quando in culo
che brutta caduta si è fatto lui a
alleluia alleluia alleluia
[Musica]
sono ritornato borga [ __ ] mahler padre
ma dal padre come si spara ops facciamo
così guarda neanche così un idiota e
devo riuscire a fini sta roba che ormai
una questione di vita o di morte
per lui è quanto incassato
[Musica]
l'ho vinto la prima volta ragazzi non lo
è perché cosa fa quella li calpesta la
faccia
infatti mettere i piedi in testa dopo
schifo e cosa non si fa per la patata
schifoso